me imagino que desde que han existido
los humanos ellos han notado que los
hijos tienen características en común
con los padres por ejemplo a lo mejor
alguien te ha dicho hey
caminas como tu papá amo tu sonrisa es
como la de tu mamá o tus ojos son como
los de tu tío o como los de tu abuelo no
lo sé pero siempre ha existido esta
noción de características heredadas pero
no fue hasta el siglo 19 que esta noción
se empezó a estudiar de una manera más
científica por gregorio méndez el padre
de la genética incluso méndez quien
empezaba a entender los mecanismos de la
herencia pensaba que existía una base
molecular detrás de ella y la respuesta
a esta pregunta no se sabía hasta hace
pocos años hasta la mitad del siglo 20
cuando la estructura del adn fue
descrita por watson y crick su trabajo
se basó en el trabajo de otros como por
ejemplo el trabajo de rosalind franklin
quien esencialmente dio todos los datos
para el trabajo de watson y crick así
como el trabajo de mauri
wilkins y muchos otros pero es justo la
estructura del adn la que hace es decir
a la gente hey esto se ve como una
molécula que guarda la información sólo
para aclarar el adn no fue descubierto
en 1953 el adn fue descubierto a
mediados del 1800 era la molécula que
estaba dentro del del núcleo de las
células y por un tiempo las personas
llegaron a pensar a lo mejor esta es la
molécula que es la base de la herencia
eso sí se sabía lo que era necesario
para hacer la base molecular de la
herencia debían ser una o una serie de
moléculas que pudieran contener
información que pudieran replicarse que
pudieran expresarse de alguna manera
pero no fue hasta en 1953 cuando esta
estructura de doble hélice del adn fue
establecida y que las personas empezaron
a decir hey esto se ve como nuestra
molécula bueno primero hablaremos acerca
de esta estructura y después hablaremos
de dónde viene el nombre de
en el ácido desoxirribonucleico y luego
de porque esta estructura es útil para
guardar información replicarla y
expresarla probablemente también
analizaremos cómo se expresa de
información pero eso en futuros vídeos
entonces esta estructura de acá arriba
es una representación visual de la
molécula del adn la puedes ver como una
escalera torcida primero tiene estos dos
lados que podemos decir que son los
lados la escalera torcida esta parte de
aquí esta parte de aquí es uno de ellos
uno de los primeros lados déjame ponerlo
con este color este de aquí y bueno
también tengo el otro que es justo este
equipo baja por acá llega acá y sería el
otro de los lados de esta escalera y
entre estos dos lados conectando a estos
puntos tenemos a la escalera torcida y
tienes estos escalones y en estos
escalones es donde está la información y
la información genética podemos
que está almacenada de alguna manera
estos escalones son una secuencia de
diferentes bases pero cuando dije a base
de seguro dijiste y espera no estábamos
hablando de un ácido porque estás
diciendo que estas son bases y bueno es
que la palabra ácido desoxirribonucleico
viene de aquí viene del hecho de que
este esqueleto este esqueleto está hecho
de una combinación de azúcar y fosfato
esta azúcar es la de c's o si ribosa y
de ahí viene la de en adn y como el
grupo de fosfato es un ácido es por eso
que se llama ácido y bueno nucleico
viene de la idea de que se encontró en
el núcleo celular y es por eso que ha
sido de socio de nucleicos
es en conjunto unas yo débil y por cada
ácido también tenemos una base y estas
bases forman los escalones que tenemos
aquí y de hecho cada escalón es un par
de pases y como dije es justo ahí donde
se almacena la información y seguramente
te estás preguntando
de qué hablo bueno déjame hablarles de
estas cuatro bases distintas que
conforman los escalones de la molécula
del adn la primera de ellas es la
adenina déjame ponerlo aquí
d
y bueno por ejemplo aquí podemos tener
tal vez una adenina ésta podría ser aquí
una adenina am se me ocurre que tal vez
por acá esto también podría ser otra
adenina aquí podríamos tener otra de
dina y no sé se me ocurre que tal vez
por acá tengamos otra otra del inah por
acá muy bien o tal vez otra por acá
déjame ponerlo sin otra adenina por acá
podemos tener varias sardinas en
nuestros escalones de la molécula del
adn se me ocurre que también por acá por
acá podemos tener otra adenina y se me
ocurre que aquí aquí también podemos
tener otra adenina otra vecina por aquí
muy bien y bueno también por aquí voy a
poner una del inah por acá
otra adelina por acá muy bien y otra por
acá voy a suponer que esta es una
avenida así que tenemos varias avenidas
como escalones de nuestra molécula de
adn pero bueno dije que cada uno de
estos escalones están hechos por un par
de bases así que la adenina siempre se
va a unir con la timina déjame ponerla
con este color avenida siempre se va a
unir con la tímida y nina es lo que
quiere decir que entonces si aquí en
este dibujo tenemos una de nina por lo
tanto el otro lado del escalón va a ser
una timina
si empiezo continuidad bueno entonces
del otro lado vamos a tener siempre una
avenida que es justo lo que pasa aquí y
si empiezo con timina entonces voy a
tener una adenina déjame ponerlo así y
si empiezo con adenina aquí voy a tener
siempre una termina estos dos siempre
están unidos aquí voy a tener aquí en
esta parte una timina empiezo con
adelina aquí tengo una tímida perfecto y
bueno si aquí empiezo con adenina por
aquí también voy a tener una timina y de
igual manera por acá aquí voy a tener
una timina ahora vamos a las otras dos
bases
voy a tener como bases también a la
guanina
la cual siempre se une siempre se va a
unir con la citosina si tú
sí así que si este de aquí éxito zidane
y entonces su par va a ser guanina altas
lo voy a poner por aquí voy a dibujar a
otras y tocina se me ocurre este de aquí
por aquí voy a dibujar a otras y tocina
muy bien por aquí voy a dibujar otra y
otra más muy bien por aquí voy a poner
otras y tocina de lujo y me falta esta
supongamos que aquí tengo otras y tocina
y bueno si tengo citocinas éstas siempre
van a estar unidas con one in us así que
por lo tanto esta de aquí va a ser una
guanina empecé con citosina entonces
procede después una guanina aquí tengo
una situación a después una guanina así
se forma el escalón si empiezo con un
one y la entonces después voy a tener
citosina si empiezo con guanina después
voy a tener citosina y por aquí también
por aquí también y bueno por aquí
también
y por aquí también por aquí también
ahora date cuenta que de hecho me faltó
este escalón de aquí y este escalón de
aquí puede ser que esté formado por
adenina timina o por wang y la citosina
no queda de otra la adenina siempre se
junta con la timina y la guanina con la
citosina así que para acabar déjame
ponerlo y así voy a suponer que este de
aquí 10 wang y la y por lo tanto se va a
unir con citosina esta parte de aquí
sería exitosa y de hecho es muy
importante que te vayas aprendiendo
todos estos nombres porque estos nombres
dicen mucho forman un tipo de código tu
código genético
y es que fíjate cuando lo dibujamos de
esta manera podemos ver todo un código
el orden en el cual las bases están
acomodadas o la secuencia de estas bases
esencialmente codifican la información
que te hace a ti ser tú bueno también
depende de cuánto influye la naturaleza
y cuánto la crianza y cuando las
personas hablan de naturaleza se refiere
a la genética y esto es un tema bastante
controversial pero esto sí codifica para
muchas cosas como el color de tu cabello
o porque cuando ves tu sonrisa es
similar a la de tus padres y todo eso es
porque esta información en gran medida
está codificada genéticamente la
genética afecta mucho de lo que te hace
a ti ser tú y de hecho no solo
diferencia entre individuos de la misma
especie sino que también diferencia
entre individuos de distinta especie los
humanos tienen más material genético en
común con otros humanos que digamos con
una planta pero eso sí todos los seres
vivos tienen información genética esta
es la base por la cual heredan sus
características y puede que ahora estás
pensando bueno cuánta información
genética tienen los humanos y el número
probablemente de excepciones o te
parezca sorprendente el genoma humano y
cada especie tiene diferente número de
pares de bases y en gran medida está
correlacionado con qué tan complejo son
pero bueno no siempre es el caso pero
bueno el genoma humano tiene tres
millones no no no no espera son tres mil
tres mil millones
y yo es de pares de bases 3 millones
sería decepcionante incluso 3 mil
millones puede ser decepcionante cuando
tú tienes el juego completo de
cromosomas y esto es la mayoría de las
células de tu cuerpo a excepción de tus
células germinales es decir los
espermatozoides o los óvulos estos pares
de bases se encuentran distribuidos a lo
largo de 46 cromosomas a lo largo de 46
cromosomas cromosomas lo que quiere
decir que aproximadamente tiene 60
millones sesenta y tantos millones de
pares de bases por el cromosoma bueno
hay algunos cromosomas que son muy
largos de hecho el más largo tiene
aproximadamente 200 millones y hay otros
más cortos pero bueno esto es un
promedio ahora bien este número 3 mil
millones puede ser un número bastante
sorprendente para algunos y puede ser
que estén pensando oh yo creí que era
una criatura simple no sabía que era tan
complejo 3
mil millones son muchísimos pares de
bases
eso suena muchísima información o bueno
tal vez otros de ustedes puede ser que
no se sientan tan genial y puede que
piensen a espera puedo almacenar toda
esta información en una usb o en un
disco duro y bueno yo pensé que era más
único que esto y bueno por supuesto
todos son únicos y especiales pero tres
mil millones de pares de bases este es
el número aproximado tal vez pensaste
que era un número infinitamente complejo
y quién sabe qué más y bueno pueden
existir argumentos en otras direcciones
pero lo que quiero que veas es que
cuando hablamos de cromosomas hablamos
más acerca de la profundidad que esto
tiene imagina no sé tomar este
acercamiento y vamos a contar cuántos
pares de bases tenemos aquí 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 7 18 son como
20 aquí tenemos cerca de 20 pares de
bases ahora imagínate que tuviéramos 2
dos millones de pares de pases y
entonces las enrollamos y tendríamos un
cromosoma y a lo mejor estás diciendo
bueno espera toda esta información en la
mayoría de las células de mi cuerpo esto
debe ser increíblemente compacto y si en
efecto esto es muy compacto el radio de
una molécula de adn déjame ponerlo con
este color si yo me fijo en este radio
que tengo aquí es aproximadamente a
aproximadamente un nanómetro un
nanómetro y recuerda que un nanómetro es
una millonésima parte de un metro
entonces te puedes imaginar la escala de
esto esta es una manera muy compacta de
almacenar información en fila ahora es
momento de hablar un poco sobre cómo se
replica la información o incluso ser
capaz de traducir o expresar la
información así que pensemos que si
fueras a tomar esta escalera que tengo
aquí y separadas los pares de bases si
separamos los pares de bases solamente
tendremos la mitad de ellos tendríamos
esencialmente la mitad
de la escalera ahora bien vamos a ver si
con la mitad de la escalera somos
capaces de construir el otro lado de la
escalera así que para eso déjame agarrar
este color tomemos un ejemplo y voy a
suponer que esta es una parte de la
escalera y digamos que bueno para
abreviar lo voy a tomar solamente la
letra inicial de cada una de estas bases
vamos a decir que esta línea blanca es
el esqueleto formado por el azúcar y el
fosfato esta parte de aquí y bueno por
aquí voy a poner algunas adén y las así
que voy a poner por aquí una del inah
otra de nina por aquí y tal vez otra del
inah otra y otra am
si no corresponderle por aquí otra de
lila no sé voy a poner por acá también
algunas tímidas así que voy a agarrar
este color y voy a poner por aquí una
timina por aquí otra timina tal vez
porque otra timina otra timina ok y
ahora voy a hacer lo mismo con guanina 6
y toxinas así que voy a empezar con wang
y las por aquí voy a tomar una guanina
imagínate que por acá tengo otra guanina
y por acá tengo otra guanina
y bueno después vamos a hacer lo mismo
con citocinas por aquí tengo una
situación a otra citocina y por acá voy
a tener otras y tocina y para finalizar
otras y tocina
imagínate que tengo esta parte de aquí
que es la mitad de mi escalera y ahora
vamos a construir la otra mitad y es
justo así como el adn se réplica esta
escalera se separa y luego cada lado de
la escalera es un molde para construir
la otra mitad o dicho de otra manera una
versión del otro lado puede ser
construida sobre esa mitad y seguro te
estás preguntando cómo sucede esto bueno
pues eso se pasa en cómo se unen estas
bases así que para eso lo primero que
quiero que te des cuenta es que la
adenina siempre se junta con la timina
siempre así que si estamos hablando de
adn y sabemos que tenemos una a por aquí
entonces tendrás por acá una t por acá
tendremos otra t por acá
y por acá otra te recuerda que la
adenina siempre se junta con la timina o
viceversa la timina siempre se junta con
la del inah así que si aquí empezó con
una tema por aquí voy a tener una am por
aquí tengo una t así que voy a tener
aquí una por acá una am y por acá voy a
tener también una a mientras que la
guanina siempre se junta con la citosina
así que si tengo una one y la voy a
poner abajo una sede citocina aquí una
sede citosina aquí una sede citocina y
las citocinas siempre se junta con la
guanina así que si tengo unas y toxinas
por aquí voy a poner aquí un agente por
aquí voy a poner también otra g por aquí
otra g y por acá otra gente ojalá esto
te haya dado una aproximación de cómo se
replica el adn y veremos cómo es que
esta información se traduce en otras
moléculas relacionadas y eventualmente
en proteínas y sólo para completar este
vídeo para que tengas una imagen real de
cómo se ve el adn o al menos que veas
una imagen distinta a ésta
y encontré este gif animado que te voy a
poner justo aquí
esta es la estructura de una doble
hélice se ve justo así estos de aquí
estos que forman el esqueleto son los
azúcares y fosfatos y son los que van a
formar todo este esqueleto de mi adn y
mientras que aquí adentro tenemos a las
bases que se van alternando una después
de otra y van formando los escalones de
esta escalera
son estos pares de bases de hecho si
tienes aquí una base vas a tener su
pareja correspondiente justo del otro
lado y así lo puedes ver a lo largo de
esta molécula en fin esto es bastante
emocionante pero por ahora aquí voy a
terminar este vídeo nos vemos en el que
sigue